well I can't sit down with you at this
year and not talk about the election
sure what is the one thing you want to
get out there to the youth of America
about this big decision we have coming
up well in this election the most
important thing you need to remember is
you have got to vote the most important
thing for kids to remember is that you
must register and vote if you don't vote
you lose the right to complain so that's
the most important thing to remember
when you look at this election Hillary
versus Trump what do you think of the
two candidates well first of all you up
to understand that it's a person who
gets into politics is a different animal
I remember in tenth grade like political
science teacher she's really really good
she said that you can't tell the public
the truth about a lot of things because
they will recoil in horror and so
politicians play that game they try to
keep their words in a way in a way that
doesn't scare the unwashed masses so
having said that all politicians are
pretty dirty if you're in politics you
dirty no it's not a bad thing just the
way it is the god it's the way the game
is played so if you think that you so
many thing to go to Washington and be
you know Mary Poppins with butterflies
and rainbows and unicorns and everyone
for you that's not how this is played
and you know that intuitively from
having gone through junior high school I
loved in a recent interview called
Hillary that's a badass [ __ ] she is and
I you know anyone who any woman or any
minority or someone who's pushed to the
side of society for them to make it
ahead in any industry in politics and
entertainment in any industry it is an
act of badassness because there's
there's so much stacked against you in a
white male dominated culture it's just
the way it is now to read it just the
way it is